welcome to Startalk radio on your host
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and joining me is my
coast today professional comedians
Startalk veteran chuck knives hey al
still tweeting a truck nice comic that's
right sir at Chuck nice comic thanks
someone else take Chuck nice actually
yes a guy who has eight followers okay
I've looked him up man like eight
followers took my name and there's
nothing you could do about it he's he's
sitting on it that stuff that stuff
today's show is gonna be all about
science literacy in the Miss information
age and once again I never do this alone
I find I comb the universe finding
people whose expertise can not only
supplement this topic but become the
topic itself and we've got with us in
studio professor David health and he's
actually a colleague of mine a fellow
astrophysicist in fact he was chairman
of Columbia's astronomy department when
I entered as a graduate student Wow
so he and I go way back it's like your
boss so he's got this book a survival
guide to the misinformation age oh
that's that's I mean could there be
anything more relevant at this
particular time
hence my blurb okay read it now the
future of civilization may depend on it
oh and I get a little more urgent than
that are we okay with that David welcome
to Startalk yes sure to be here Neil and
you can all fairness David you even and
even though we just made those
statements about the timeliness of the
book you were you were a bit foretelling
because this you wrote last year right a
couple years ago few years it came out
less a little yours came out a year ago
this week but you actually wrote it a
couple of years so you are you like it
was it was building you know which
building it's not just this
you saw the writing on the wall a big
step up in the last a couple months but
I think it's been building for a while
that's you and just for those who are
only listening to this right David
health fan has a Santa Claus beard and
mustache just to be clear that's cool
though yeah
I just keep you wanted the celebrity you
must you must get spoke and he smells to
say guys always say you work in malls I
work in the North Pole which is almost
not there anymore right so David how do
you characterize are there some signs
that you point to and say here is the
best example of this age that we've just
entered well the first problem with this
age is the amount of information or
misinformation IBM estimated recently
that we generate about 2.5 quintillion
bytes of information per day Wow on
earth and if you're not used to
quintillion you are neelam 2.9
quintillion hollowed by 18 zeros and if
you printed it out it would fill a
bookcase that stretched around the earth
of the equator and was half a kilometer
high if you printed out that information
that we generated per day today ok
that's 185 thousand pages per person per
day but is it meaningful information how
do you edit 185 thousand pages per day
they don't over do snow probably not
right so that's part of the problem
there uh-huh
and so it's absent curation it's
completely absent curation now when we
were living in hunter-gatherer groups
there of 30 people information was very
limited we didn't have a lot of
libraries of something but it was
accurate because if you were the guy who
led the hunting party to the hungry
lions instead of the zebras you know you
didn't you never came back emanated from
the gene pool really the stupid gene now
those were the days now if you don't
know who you're propagating information
to you just send it out to millions of
people right you do it all the time
right right millions and if you don't
know those people then you have no
investment in their survival and so if
misinformation that enhances your fame
or power or wealth or something or your
politics and your fame and power and
wealth then why not provide
misinformation regardless of its impact
on those who receive the information
because you don't know them you know ok
so this is what you're saying is we are
victims of something that was quite
useful in the past and now has in a way
become our enemy that's right our
evolutionary
me sort of like fat I did not expect him
to say that that's a great a true it's
completely true it really does
yeah fat was like holy it's like a high
density calorie exactly five what was
your friend doing those lean times quote
unquote those lean times being fat was a
wonderful thing so it's a Survival Guide
so is this the beginning of a movement
to recognize yes there is this
information it's not going to go away so
now here's a recipe how to sift through
it and make sense of it and judge what
is and what is not true Wow precisely
because you know your browser's not
gonna do that for you when you google
something it just spits back whatever is
that why can't it well that's an
interesting question why doesn't it
isn't might be the question I give just
a fast reference to this before browsers
John Allen Paulus is a friend and
mathematician I heard him once say and
this is before the era of search engines
he said the Internet is great the
problem is all the books are scattered
on the floor at that time you didn't
know how to access information filtered
by your interest now we have search
engines that's not a problem anymore
you can sift through it billions of
pages in a fraction of a second it's
handed to you on a silver platter and
who would have thought that that created
this next level of challenge that
perhaps we need some next level a
browser to handle for us what do you use
it on the horizon or not well I don't
know it would be a challenge to write
one I think now of course everybody
assumes the filters that are put on by
various internet companies are all
politically motivated right you need one
that's science motivated I think what
science filter or a science browser
science brother that's not what you
really mean is is a [ __ ] filter
that's what yeah but that's that's what
the browser could do I think you still
have to have some judgment involved in
how to assess the evidence and that's
what the book tries to do it tries to
give you those tools like I say it
installs those what's a good tool give
me top top three tools top top three
tools first is being able to make
estimates
just using simple arithmetic being able
to estimate whether something makes
sense or not you know almost every day
in the established media the gray lady
even there are mistakes by a factor of a
thousand by a factor of a million you
know and no one pays any attention
because they don't notice it you can
look at they don't even know how to
think about it now to think about it but
it don't care what you say there were
millions of people there millions upon
millions I saw them with my own eyes
okay so that would be a failure of an
estimate in that case okay
second information is second filter is
having some idea of the way the physical
world works I mean the problem is that
we live in an age of magic right arthur
c clarke said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic one of his edicts yes right with
his third law I believe and so knew what
the first and second law oh the first
law is if if if a scientists an old
scientist who looks like me tells you
something's impossible he's probably
wrong he's unfortunate in this day and
age because of this problem but let's
let's stick with the third law
so in sufficiently advanced technology
indistinguishable from magic
so what did we live in we live in this
world is little box on the car and it
speaks to you and it knows exactly where
you are at all times those were grandma
lives and how to get there right so why
shouldn't talking to your dead relatives
be reasonable right no and this guy
shines a little light in your eye for 30
seconds you don't need glasses anymore
why shouldn't magnets Curie or arthritis
you know so it's all just magic and in
the world of magic who knows about magic
you know astrologers psychics homeopathy
see this mean science has been a little
too successful well it's too successful
in the sense that has changed things too
fast to us for us to be able to adapt so
and so what you're saying in essence is
in order for us to actually understand
science the way we should we have to
create a society filled with little
scientists like we all have to be
literate science literate we all have to
be scientists in some way shape or form
and we all are until we're about five or
six years old explore but David I don't
know okay so I try to evaluate every
statement I make hoping that I never
a statement that betrays some kind of
old man on the porch point-of-view me
you've never tweeted you kids get off my
lawn you K you kids go play one of he
that old man and so you just said yeah
information happening too quickly for us
let me let me perhaps get you out of the
old man syndrome and say maybe it's not
that discoveries are happening too
quickly because my kids are not
complaining about being overwhelmed by
data all right it's older folk who come
from an era where there weren't wasn't
that much data maybe what you want to
say is we need tandem educational
curricula so that we understand how the
world works rather than just be fed
volumes of of science information
thinking that's what makes you
scientifically literate when the real
source of science literacy is not what
you know but how you think about the
world is that fair that's exactly right
so the whole model of Education as
information transfer makes no sense
makes no sense right you've thought
about this you found it you you
co-founded a university a brand-new
university in Canada and I hear you're
at it again in some other place where
the UK in the UK just tell me what you'd
which cuz you didn't just come out of
nowhere out of a cave to say this hmm
you put you you you did it what did you
do you know are you being sued by the
New York Attorney General okay now go
ahead that's the other guy okay okay
well yes so the idea is instead of
feeding people information you have them
construct knowledge mmm construct their
own knowledge out of what they know and
a little bit of guidance shoving them
down a path takes much longer much
harder it's much harder it takes much
longer doesn't matter if you don't have
to transfer all this information cuz
it's much longer and harder I'm gonna
take you up on that because I've I'm not
so if I understand what you mean when
you say construct your own knowledge
okay I'll give you a good example we're
strong we can talk about astronomy yeah
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah so when we
discover all these planets around other
stars
and that's that so planet it's a planet
it's amazing race it is twenty years ago
we knew no planets except ours and then
we know it so how do we do that well we
have to know how planets move so Kepler
figured this out in 1610 you know
figured out how the planets write down
three laws of planetary motion so a
Columbia huh I go to a blackberry write
down the three laws of planetary motion
and my students all copy him down even
though it's sitting in the under fifty
dollar textbook next to them and then I
say how long has take the earth to go
around the Sun all right and they sort
of look at me and finally someone says a
year and I said well let's see if that
works and you plug in the numbers of the
period and the semi-major axis of the
Eclipse and they write all that down and
then you send them home and they do it
for how long it takes more is to go
around the Sun right and you know then
on the test you make it real tricky you
say how long to take you're open to go
around Jupiter you know and then figure
out to change the mass but they get
their a's and they go away and they're
happy that's just feeding information to
people
ratch yeah all right so that takes 20
minutes at Qwest question the name of
the University in Canada right it's
three hour classes five days a week
three hours a day I walk into class I
give them this little simulation about
planets going around other stars fifteen
parameters they don't know what any of
them are okay give them a sheet of a few
questions they say well see what this
see what happens if you change this and
keep this one fixed okay I think about
what this eye means here and then I'll
um play gotcha and three and a half
hours later they stayed a half hour
after class someone got up and wrote
down Kepler's three laws
I never mentioned Kepler we never
mentioned three laws that's they had
constructed that's we can amazing so
therefore they will not be susceptible
to being handed information I eight
others right now they won't remember
Kepler's law as I don't remember kept
will you remember cut the process
matters but the process remember you
look at information you can look for
patterns in it you can cast those
patterns in a mathematical form you can
use that to predict the way something
else behaves that's all you want you're
testing and those are tools it's a
toolkit for learning how the world works
and you can construct one for biology
and chemistry and the reason is because
you already know how the world works but
helps right it
don't put words in David's mouth but
what it does is he since David already
knows how the worlds work what works he
knows that the work the world can be
figured out from this set of four puts
down on a tag and so in yeah there's a
lot that science knows about how the
world works
Hey way more than many people would even
recognize right is the level it's
amazing so that was two so you have a
third one or did we go through three
already I I don't know I can't count
that okay so one is estimate estimations
do is only how the world works how the
world works three oh well I'm a bunch of
probability and statistics I would be
nice well we'd be having an idea that
whether something's likely or not likely
recognizing that the you know the plural
of anecdote is not data you know that
something happens to you it doesn't mean
that it's highly significant I'm sorry
you just you sent a chill down my back
cuz I gotta tell you that is the thing
right now anecdotal evidence seems to be
taken as fact for so many people and I
don't get it it's like yet did that
happen to you there's another one of the
cleanest examples of this I remember was
back in the day when Japanese cars were
much safe much more reliable right at
American cars now they've all kind of
got their you know raise their game yeah
but so here you are you ready to buy a
Honda Accord because Consumer Reports
highly rates it okay and it hardly ever
fails on the road and and the like and
someone walks out of the dealership and
and looking frustrated and you say well
what's the matter well I just returned
my Honda Accord it was it was awful I
said what happened oh it's the worst car
I've ever driven on it broke three miles
down a thing and I've been and then you
decide to not buy the Honda Accord
because of this one person who says not
the volume of data from Consumer Reports
by the way they made seven million other
cars that year probably evolutionary as
well you want the passion of your your
friend and your own experience I mean
you know that the tiger chases you up
the tree you know that's that's a that
gets lodged in your amygdala there
that's that's something that's going to
trigger a response all the time right
but and it happened to you and then it
probably mattered but you know when you
walk into the subway and well that's the
example I used in the book right so I
was going out to see my mother-in-law in
Staten Island and I got on the train and
the train went a few stops then it
stopped and someone had fallen under the
tracks right and so I think gee how
often does that happen in New York you
know
so I later looked it up but I have never
seen it happen cause it to happen coming
back the same weekend happened again
mm-hmm you late the odds in the books 22
million to one so if you're on a jury
and I'm charged with killing two people
by shelling in front of the subway
because it happened 22 million to one
against you vote to convict right but I
had nothing to do with it cuz it's a
completely random occurrence happens 40
times a year out of billion million
people ride the subway
so it's billion paying customers billion
fares that's amazing no but you're right
it's probably the safest thing you could
do
statistically with respect to that
anecdote right well that's amazing well
this is in fact a cosmic query version
of Startalk which we will begin to
solicit from Chuck yes goddamn they
waited ready for us after this
commercial break when we come back to
Startalk
we're back on Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist I'm
here with Chuck nice yes me to co-host
Greta and we I've got in studio not only
a friend and astrophysics colleague he's
written a book on science literacy
called a survival guide to the
misinformation age David halfan
professor David Hill fan great to have
you on the show
great to be here all right so let's go
right back into the conversation we have
cosmic queries yes we do and by the way
this is the second installment of cosmic
queries let's make America smart again
yes it's a subcategory of cosmic queries
absolutely let's do it give a ten of
course we always first of all we get
them from all over so whenever you see
the call go out make sure you answer it
whether it's on Twitter or Facebook or
what-have-you but we also take questions
from our patreon patrons first I'd you
know that's so cheap so people give you
money we'll give us money I will never
get and we priority on your case every
time you say oh I know Neil doesn't like
it but I think it's great I think is so
American there we go all right let's
start off with Mark Miller from patreon
who says this in a world of alternative
facts with taking the social media to
confront the source of the quote-unquote
alternative facts be at all constructive
or helpful and Mark is coming to us from
Halifax Nova Scotia yeah my sense is
it's not that there's a false fact
because someone happened to get it wrong
that they're false facts is because
that's how they want it to be true and
if you actively want a false fact to be
true I don't I wonder does your book
have any access to that mind at all yeah
that's a good question it's I mean
social media is designed to construct
echo chambers right all of your beliefs
are reinforced right and as does a
Google search Google search the most the
weirdest non true thing and you'll find
the website dedicated to that yeah well
if I say in the book if you do
Google search on age of the earth you
know radioactive dating and you know
some ninth grader might get assign that
topic right six of the first ten things
that come up prove that radioactivity is
nonsense and the earth is ten thousand
years old really Google you tried it now
I'm sorry I'm trying it right now okay
so so therefore having correct
information in the face of
misinformation clearly doesn't work it's
a problem it's a problem well that's not
have you on the show to tell me it's a
problem I want to show to tell me how to
solve it it's the salt the solution is
changing the education education so
we're not okay so you have to give up on
the whole leaf I'm actually told what
David said I cannot believe the crap
that is coming up on Google right now
this is unbelievable we have no
scientific method can prove the age of
the Earth and the universe and that
includes the ones that are listed here
holy crap you're allowed to say that
yeah well so that it's a free country
yeah the democratization of information
is good it just comes with this big
baggage with a responsibility many
different processes are used - oh my god
and it's all and I got it I only want to
say where the sources are from because I
don't even want to get into that but
this is so what you have to advertise
them but this is what you have to do so
what you have to do it seems is everyone
else was a goner you've got it then
changed the educational curricula keep
their curiosity first of all so they
question everything that you do that for
free do that for for when they're young
enough we beat it out of them right yeah
yeah completely
and then concern how to construct
knowledge for themselves so they can use
these tools I call them the little you
know apps to install in your prefrontal
cortex that filter this information in a
way this is G does that make any sense
can I figure out if that makes sense
I love that so what do you do when
you're confronted with with work
actually call them worldviews
which we call it a a at we say political
bias for the most yep they don't but
they wouldn't think they're biased when
you're in it so I don't want to call it
that that's an end and echo chamber has
been been bandied about but then that's
almost still soulful to where you're
saying what do you call it from the
perspective of the person who actually
believes it okay so exactly so it would
just be what is your cultural political
religious philosophy there it is and if
that conflicts with fact with
objectively true facts it just doesn't
matter to people well that's right but
but but you can if you work at it you
can get people usually to agree on a few
facts earth is round okay all right
sorry we interrupted go on could you
bumming me out here but going yeah I was
thinking we're making progress
we got our own bubble do you think we're
making progress in our own bubble but we
read our feeds and people are you doing
a good job you know attaboy
you know and we say hey and then you
come at us with this and you got to go
look you got to Google the damn age of
the universe no idea uh-huh it's never
been the case that the entire global
population all seven point four billion
of these Homo sapiens understood
everything about the universe right
that's never been the case right the
problem now we're in the we're in the
the the death of expertise right I mean
expertise is elite and lead is evil and
therefore we have to abolish all of that
oh by the way I blame some of that on
scientists on yeah on the elite the
intellectually elite because I think
there's and there's an attitude involved
that others are just not with them and
if they how could they possibly even
want
vote for someone who the elite does not
vote for right and I think it came back
and bit him in the ass no it's exactly
right I scientists are also responsible
I'm the level of hype that goes out with
press releases when you publish some
paper and it's completely out of
proportion to the result you'd see the
reproducibility crisis and sorry about
the reproducibility crisis alright so in
in and out by the way now your talk
about a problem in the scientific side
and inside you let the public alone for
the moment it's just my own house okay
go
so Amgen some years ago did a study so
the pharmaceutical a bio bio chemical
company right and they took 53 studies
that we're not just published in
peer-reviewed journals this is on cancer
for cancer looking for cancer drugs okay
53 studies not just published but
highlighted in the editorials of the
issue of the journal they were in as
potential major breakthroughs and they
put a whole bunch of people on it put a
whole bunch of money and it tried to
reproduce them 89% of those studies were
a reproducible Wow it's bad that's bad I
want to say that's not a good number so
just to be clear for people to know what
how when a scientist use of the word
irreproducible that doesn't mean they
couldn't figure out the experiment it
means they did the experiment did not
get the same results so that's what
every producible means and so if you
don't get the same result then one is
wrong the others right the other is
wrong that is right or they're both
wrong right you they both can't be right
that's right and so this is a problem
this is a problem just recently very
energetic psychologists rounded up a
couple hundred of his colleagues and
tried to reproduce a hundred and
some-odd I forget how many there were
experiments that have been published in
behavioral psychology okay you know of
order half of them could not be
reproduced after them couldn't be
reproduced so so what is this
attributable to I mean it's is it is it
a matter just to be clear has to be
clear and David round this out but it's
going to be clear there is no
requirement cosmic requirement that your
research will ultimately be shown to be
correct okay
most research is shown to be either
unimportant or uninteresting or
sometimes wrong right there's no wrong
do
there but when you want to assert a new
emergent scientific truth you cannot
link it to a single research result
that's it because we recognize as a
community that we can have bias we're
human like anybody else and I can advise
I didn't know about so now I get I do an
experiment David comes in it's oh well
you know I love you Neil but let me just
double check you and he gets a different
result finds out I made an error or
maybe we both made errors and you need a
third person to come in and show that
that happens too so you don't give your
thesis that will not be broached in this
garbage
Wow so now so we so is there a solution
here because the ones highlighted by the
editor at the beginning of the journal
this is good for the tenure prospects of
potential researchers and it's
self-feeding okay exactly it's this
publication bias you get a negative
result you don't publish it because it's
not interesting you get a positive
result well if you do anything 20 times
you're likely to get one positive result
that's what it's even not even true not
even true right just as on the
statistical distribution just a
fluctuations like what you wanted it to
be so that's why got there so that's the
first problem the second problem is well
you know what that's call is called the
the the sharpshooter effect or the
bullseye effect where so you you you
fire arrows into the side of a barn
right you look to where all they can
where they collect it and then you draw
a bull's eye like this grouping here as
you say there's this pressure to get
grants and so you have to produce
positive results to get your next grant
and you have to get grants cuz you have
to get tenure and you have tenure by
publishing in prestigious journals we
and there's no currency for duplicating
someone else's result well of course
that in the scientific method there is
that's that's the ultimate way of
showing something is more probable
rather than less probable reproduce and
you should always publish the methods
you use such that someone else could
reproduce your wrist if you put your
money where your mouth is you were
chairman of
the Astronomy Department at Columbia for
20 years how many some some order
something like that okay and you were
there young you were chairman before you
were 40 so would you have tenured
someone that devoted their career just
to duplicating other people's research
well interesting question is a good
question just calling you out I'm just
just just keep it as light as the Larry
Wilmore would say keep a hundred is it
the fact that you guys have made that
whole thing too sexy to begin with as
Neil knows I refuse to accept tenure
when it was offered to me and I'm not a
fan of the tenure system that is
academic gangster we give you 1000
stinking Pena give me a five-year
contract and only if I'm good after five
years exact or a new it oh my god you're
like my wife and that she was like you
could leave me anytime you want this one
of us in this relationship that won't
have a problem finding somebody else
least give you a five-year contract
awesome so so you agree to this yeah so
that's the challenge I mean just simply
reproducing someone else's results no
reproducing them in a different way that
comes at it from a slightly different
tack that supports or refutes the result
sure I think what you don't know in
advance if it's gonna refute I would
have committed five years of my life
yeah it's a choice years of my life
weren't being reviewed for hiring and
for tenure and I say these three
research results are spot-on
now give me tenure I'm last in your line
of hires well yes to me in my line in
but I agree that that's the general view
yes that that is the general view and in
science okay so interesting so what it
also means though let me let me try to
fix this if more than half of all
research papers are not reproducible
that means this could be a new cottage
industry it certainly could and in fact
what's been proposed in cycle
which I really like is you have to
publish your methods and your hypotheses
and everything in advance now we know
your motivation where you're coming from
all that your funders to me your funders
it's all out on the table it's so
transparent that you cannot once you
have your results you cannot you can no
longer alter those rich cherry pickers
figure out or figure out draw the bull's
eye you already drew the bull's eye it's
like it's like somebody falling down the
steps and all they have to say I mean to
fall down the steps in this next exactly
right very good
ice so in our field there's also of
course bias from funding sources which
we are less susceptible to as
astrophysicist who's nobody's funding
you period Pfizer doesn't care what the
black hole exact the space-time
continuum is doing unless unless there's
a big zit inside you know Clearasil
getting back to our own wheelhouse our
own our own community of scientists the
bias that would result from one source
having some expectation that's obviously
stronger in other fields than in ours
but in your survival guide to
misinformation the scientists are
participants in the misinformation when
you are biased by your funding sources
that's certainly true I think in our
field it's really easy first of all
there is easy talk through what's the
record of the sky right you can't I mean
you can't mess with it oh yeah yeah
that's true so someone else can I just
discover a comet between here and here
now and yeah the other thing is we have
these beauties where you take data it
goes in that repository anybody else can
go in there and look at that that's the
raw data the raw data
true we don't it's very hard to
manipulate raw data right it just comes
out of the telescope the detector it
goes in and we are more data it's like
gold to us it's public right bet and
that's an emergent fact about our field
that the the wrought your raw data when
it's publicly funded public all the time
goes public right on the bat right off
the bat like that's the way it should
just be though okay
yeah but otherwise yeah we don't know
what do you do with your data by under
the table hey right we've we got it we
got it would take a quick break when we
come back more of science literacy than
the age this information with my friend
and colleague David halfan when star
talk continues we are back on star talk
radio talking about science literacy and
its relation to the Miss information age
we've got this book written by David
halfan published by Columbia University
Press I got funny man Chuck nice here
yes sir alright this is a cosmic queries
yes it is the subcategory of cosmic
query which we call let's make America
smart again absolutely and I think you
got me give me another question I got a
great question here from Rob Paul Davis
coming to us from Facebook and he says
this I have a hard time accepting dark
matter utterly undetectable matter by
direct means that cannot be any
substance that we already know of what
are the possible alternatives are there
to explain this supposed missing gravity
hmm David let me let me shape that
question for you into your into your
center there so you said earlier in the
brought in in the show there's crazy
things that we as scientists are saying
is true and then we schastie someone for
thinking that crystals rubbing them
together will heal them which sounds way
more possible than the existence of dark
matter so would you come at it with that
so it's basically hard to believe
science truths and false believable
truths how about the
yeah III try to avoid the word truth
when it comes to science you know
mathematicians can prove things true
scientists just make ever better
approximations to the way the universe
works
so Dark Matter is a current
approximation okay and it is detectable
in that we can detect its gravitational
influence on things that move around in
it okay
so it's it we just can't see it with our
eyes but seeing with our eyes is not the
only way you can detect stuff mm-hmm
it is is a hypothesis and there are
alternatives matter right right
alternative hypotheses that Newton's
laws or line Stein's laws of gravity on
scales vastly greater than we can
directly experience okay it's slightly
different it'd be a little tiny bit
different and then that'll explain the
way stars move around instead of the
postulating that there's six times more
gravity right what it what it
fundamentally is is in apps it's dark
gravity right it's really what it should
have been called that is a an
observational fact the fact that we call
it dark matter is I don't even like
using the term right the reason because
it's this lead that leads the listener
yeah it makes me think that it's not
that's just that you've gone away from
talking about gravity right right we're
still talking about gravity no matter
what I really that I'm airily right so
do you have a way to get around that
because in your lectures there would be
a kind when you say the whole universe
wants fit inside of a marble and why are
we gonna believe that at all how do you
where's the believability they're out
there again it's a model right that's
what we do we'd kill models of the way
things work
so we have a model that makes
predictions now Dark Matter you know
we've been going through various
hypotheses are they dead stars are they
missing runaway planets and we knock
those off one of the time no no reliably
I Drive it adheres reliably yeah there
are some things we haven't knocked off
yet are they little subatomic particles
from some other part of the particles zu
zu that we aren't familiar with yet
right people are working really hard
spend a lot of time and money and effort
to try to find them the over-under on
that is that that's where people are
leaning if you have to lean if you're a
betting scientist you'd lean towards a
new family of particles that don't
interact with ours
okay that's yeah that's that's where the
most money is being spent right
direction right
and and how much validity which is not
the right word what kind of evidence is
showing us that that may be where we
need to continue the search again it's
it's what we keep eliminating so we've
eliminated huge numbers of these
fantastical subatomic particles okay
can't fit they can't fit the bill okay
so we narrow and narrow and narrow if we
if we shrink it all the way down to zero
like there's no phase space left there's
no there's no possible range of masses
and energies and things for these
particles well then we've eliminated
that as a possibility but that's a
little harder so that's basically how
that is how we roll right on that when
it's done sensibly and and with a
directed mission statement so so yeah I
mean it's it's it's I'd like the idea
when you say it's it's it's a model
because what we're describing fits the
data available to us right or it is not
violated in the absence of data yet
right right so all of this it's it's
this it's this contest on the frontier
of knowledge that that goes on every day
so what Rob Rob should know is that this
is an ongoing process I'm going pro so
no one is saying definitively this is
the deal what we're saying is in our
best knowledge this is where we are now
and I'd like David's second opinion on
this I would say that no longer is
science reporting in the news a major
weak point in this problem and I've seen
this hugely talented science reporters
out there
that by and large get it right or they
get it right enough so that they're not
the ones that we can point to in this
but a little last peeve I have is when
they say oh this new discovery about
dark matter could send scientists back
to the drawing board no we are always at
the drum always at first if you were not
at the drawing board you were not on the
frontiers not like you went Dark Matter
might eyes for every hit the pool you
know just go good yeah I got you okay
all right cool anyone give me one it's
new Vaughn that Christopher lean and
Christopher says this fact : a noun
that is indisputably the case maybe we
should stop calling things that are
disputable facts so I think his his
point in this is there's a lot of fact
talk being bandied about about things
that maybe are not facts indeed so in
science is a fact something that is
indisputable here from the Davis lad how
do you do well I have a definition of a
fact that I use in my talks on climate
change for example a fact is a
measurement of some physical quantity
done with the best available equipment
vetted through skeptical review and
provisional with an uncertainty
associated with it okay all right
so wait wait so chuck is sitting to my
left is that a fact that is a fact
because I can measure that okay okay
left depends on the point view right to
my left I said yes yes no question there
are three of us sitting here that's okay
so measurement matters isn't it matter
measurement matters so it's not a fact
if Jesus is my Savior that's a personal
it's a very personal thing that you
cannot measure by these tools so we so
just don't even use it whatever you want
to call it you just don't use the word
fact right right okay I agree with okay
okay good
ultra suede is amazing fact okay all
right did you agree with the rather
harsh but I think mostly true statement
that after the laws of physics
everything else is opinion well that's
really it's it's it's audacious it's
audacious how it depends on your how
broad your definition of physics is I
mean I don't think it's physics that the
three of us are sitting here we can
count up to three I mean that's not
really physics right for yourself there
David if you're counting you're not
measuring it's an important distinction
that's why there's no measure of an
error when you're counting well this is
not 3 plus or minus 1/2 right this is 3
exactly yeah
but it's it's 67 million votes plus or
minus a few hundred thousand because you
can't count them perfectly right so you
counting in that case right right okay
that's yeah okay that's it all right
here we go I keep it going here we go
this is
Munir after this we go to lightning
round a little anywhere after this cause
Jeff Munir who says with the US only
representing four point four percent of
the world's population does trying to
legislate climate really do any good
David well it's just like climate in the
United States he's talking about global
no no no he's saying if we we do
something we do it he meant that because
we're such a significant portion of the
world's population should we have the
right to tell the world I don't think
that's true I understand what you're
saying you're saying he's saying since
was such a small portion on the
population if we do something will it
make a difference at all okay how about
both of those questions right so firstly
we produce twenty two percent of the
greenhouse gases so yeah well there you
have a factor of five and there used to
be a concept of American leadership in
the world has to be is the correct word
there and so taking a leadership
position would be addressing a problem
which 99 point something percent of the
scientific community is in consensus on
all right it makes sense so we go in
lightning round okay we know this is
where all answers must be in soundbite
form so we can get through as many
questions as possible and this is
reminiscent David of my PhD thesis
defense you served on my committee and I
get I give my most in you know my best
thesis defense and at the end you said
okay now how would you explain this to a
reporter from The New York Times
this is the last like two minutes of the
the thing and I'm deep in the sky right
you know I'm deep in the stuff and he's
been requiring that of anyone to
graduate from the the astro department
at Columbia so now this is my version of
this we went through the details now
it's can you turn it into a sound bite
all right there's the Bell let's do it
go how the limb has tend william photo
Tim from Facebook is there any merit or
a good idea of global Space Agency
science is almost the internationally
connected any way on the planet send
space agencies all over the world are
already collaborating on dozens of
projects how long will it be eventually
before we're able to do things like send
people
out of the solar system just like he
wants a United Federation of Federation
of Planets I think it'll be a long time
and it will come about when the notion
of a nation-state disappears imagine the
world a world government leo Beale says
this with reference to wf9 I know people
are worried about it will hit the earth
however we won't see a close enough
approach until December 20 55 even if
that is the case close enough to do
anything about January 26th III it comes
real close what can we do and should we
do about it now maybe killer asteroids
worry okay ready let me finish a sense
ready we're worried enough to put into
play what we already know to do under
that situation but do not yet have the
wisdom or the foresight to act right
Derek C Burke wants to know this Siebert
wants to know this how much farther
ahead would we be if the Dark Ages were
avoided and do you think the Dark Ages
are making a comeback
David Dark Ages are definitely making a
comeback
okay but we wouldn't be any further
ahead because the Dark Ages were only in
a little isolated part of the world that
we used to worry about other places at
the same time we're experiencing a
wonderful flowering of intellectual
passion okay that's a good answer but
let me come back at you we think of the
Dark Ages as closing off the
intellectual technological enlightenment
of the Roman Empire so the Roman Empire
did not fall and their interest in
architecture and and engineering had
continued what do you think that would
have eventually fallen for some other
reason or my dad is still stuck with
Europe yeah I think empires are designed
to fall Tina says this since you're a
professor David as a science teacher in
a public school how do i balance a
teaching inquiry and questioning without
being politically correct about my
students beliefs David well I think it
was separate belief
from facts and questioning is the
critical component of that but but if
someone has a belief system that
conflicts with facts as they emerge from
a scientific community then you were
teaching something that is directly in
the face of their beliefs then what do
you do
but don't challenge their beliefs
people's beliefs serves you know that's
really tough okay just let them have
their beliefs beliefs fine we don't
believe what they want sighs we're gonna
do a little exercise now like we grew
exercise in the playground we're gonna
do exercise with our brains uh-huh and
we're going to see where this chain of
logic leads us right Mitchell wants to
know this how should society government
teachers deal with the anti-science
folks or whatever you want to label them
teaching these things to their children
listen at home so I would imagine
Mentors Oh home schoolers is what he's
talking about or school boards that get
cool right their children I would
imagine telling their children the
things that their textbooks and teachers
tell them are outright lies so what do
you do you do David this information
forget misinformation disinformation
educators go again I think you teach
people to construct their own knowledge
you don't pass them information on this
information or disinformation you teach
them how to construct their own
knowledge and that'll make them question
those parents Wow love it David yes you
killed it dude killed it you killed it
David halfan special guest today old
friend old professor looks like Santa
Claus if you don't you're gonna have to
subscribe to Startalk all-access comm
you can see what David looks like so
this closes out this edition of cosmic
queries which is a special subcategory
called let's make America smart again
Chuck nice here is my co-host and this
is David health fans book a survival
guide to the misinformation age
published by Columbia University Press
it's subtitled scientific habits of my
nice on it he's in it because that's how
he rolls
this has been Startalk cosmic queries
let's make America smart again to dition
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson and as always I
bid you to keep looking up
[Music]